deschamps et du tambour en plein coeur
de rome pour souligner l'importance du
moment la procession est solennel
l'émotion est palpable
la chef de la communauté de kamloops se
sent prête après des années d'attenté
une visite rapportés par l'aco vide
c'est enfin au tour de délégués des
premières nations de se rendre au
vatican pour y rencontrer le pape
la patience des survivants des
pensionnats finalement été récompensés
la rencontre avec le pape françois durez
deux fois plus longtemps que prévu que
ce soit pour décrire les abus physiques
et sexuels ou les tentatives d facile
leur identité
les délégués ont pu prendre le temps
d'expliquer au chef de l'église
catholique toute la douleur causée par
les pensionnats
mais de ce sombre récit semble avoir
jailli une certaine lumière un
rapprochement comme dans la célèbre
peinture qui en la chapelle sixtine
dévoile
le pas françois semble avoir pris toute
la mesure de l'importance de ces
témoignages pour les délégués par les
deux communes y en a
cyan même dit que ce soir priez pour
nous répondre de m je pense que la
délégation
le pape n'a pas donné d'indicés sur les
maux qui prononcera vendredi mais dans
leur quête d' excuses les premières
nations sur et près du but
il a écouté les délégués toute la
semaine et c'est finalement demain que
le pape prendra la parole après des
années d'attenté on verra enfin si et
comment le chef de l'église catholique
répondra aux demandes d'excusés
autochtone du canada ici mathieu weill
et radio-canada rome